(audience applauding)
Okay Rossy, what's next?
Okay, well,
we've got a woman named Nikki Jabs,
who went viral on TikTok.
BuzzFeed reports Nikki's date
sent her home in an Uber,
because he was embarrassed of her outfit.
(Ross growls)
And you can see it here.
Apparently he felt--
She looks cute,
I will say,
in this little pink coat and pink pants.
Well, he thought she was too overdressed
for his work event at an athleisure company,
so, he just dialed-up an Uber
and sent her home,
and then she broke up with him.
But she's like sobbing,
Yes.
in the back of the cab.
'Cause it's so rude to do to somebody.
This woman is literally sobbing with tears
in the back of a car,
because this guy made her feel so bad
about--
Like, what is his problem?
I have no idea,
and I have to tell you, like, if you're dating somebody
who makes you feel that way,
I hope to mourn the relationship,
you wear a sequence, honey.
That's what I hope you wear,
because this is unacceptable.
(audience applauding)
I mean...
This disappoints me,
I'm not gonna lie.
But do you know what I love?
I love that she ended their relationship,
that she stood up for herself.
So many times--
Have you ever done this?
If somebody says, I don't like this about you,
you try to change it to make them happy?
Do you?
(fingers tapping)
Well,
I think he actually did her an incredible favor,
because he showed his cards
right away on what a toxic human being
that he is.
It's disappointing,
but I'm glad he quickly and swiftly did this,
so that she never has to deal with a guy
like this again.
And I bet coming out of this,
she'll get a huge response,
'cause this is everywhere right now.
So, something good will come out of this for her,
out of the grief.
I hope so too.
(audience applauding)
I'm glad he showed her
who he was.
(audience applauding)
And this guy,
you know?
I'd like to tell him a few things.
(Ross chuckles)
I'd like to watch you do that.
Oh, I just want to
(Ross giggles)
eviscerate him.
I really do.
He's lucky even to have a date.
Loser.
(Ross chuckling)
I'm sorry,
did I say that out loud?
Yep, you did.
We all heard it.
Yeah.
Okay, sorry.
(Ross chuckling)
Just, you know what?
I wish--
He's not a loser,
he's cruel,
I don't understand cruel people.
No, he's a loser,
'cause he lost her,
sorry.
That's right!
Sorry.
Thank you.
All right, and finally it's time
for a pick from Drew's Little Yellow Book
that's isn't our stuff,
(audience applauding)
that I personally curate for you,
because I want you to know about it.
It's on our website,
we refresh it every week,
I take this thing
very seriously.
(Ross chuckles)
Okay, I am totally obsessed with--
I know I'm really late to this party,
but I don't care.
Yellowstone.
I am loving
this show
so much.
It's like if you like Succession,
you're gonna love Yellowstone.
And if you're not really big
into snappy New York-y stuff,
but you love like family,
high stakes,
big powerhouse kind of themes,
it's just so rich.
I love it.
Okay, everybody's talking
about this show,
and it's been out
for a couple of years, right?
Yes.
But it's having this major moment.
I can't recommend it enough more.
It is just great,
great, great, television,
and I see what all the fuss is about,
and now that there's four seasons out,
you can just binge yourself to heaven,
so--
Okay.
Actually, oh my gosh.
We have a clip
(Ross gasps)
from the show.
Take a look.
The new chief is hungry for a fight.
I'm gonna buy your ranch
(suspenseful music)
and I'm gonna pull down every fence.
It looked like it used to
when it was ours.
Just tell me who to fight.
Everyone.
(audience applauding)
All right, you know what? (audience applauding)
You convinced me to watch Bridgerton,
you convinced me to watch Emily in Paris,
and now I'm gonna watch this show,
because you recommend it.
Well, and if you go on our website,
we did a theme week,
and it's literally our entire watchlist.
And there are so many good picks,
it's very diverse,
it's very genred
and it is just--
I research watchlists all the time,
because I love binging TV,
and I'm always looking.
Our Watchlist is like really good,
so, check it out.
I trust your TV palate
Because
you get so much information
(audience applauding)
that it's like you forget.
Wait, what was that thing
(audience applauding)
I wanted to watch?
Go to our list on thedrewbarrymoreshow.com,
the Drew's Little Yellow Book,
we got your back.
(upbeat music)
(upbeat music fades)